man c'est à dire il nous a menti au
moins sur l'usagé qu'il avait des armes
sur ces autorisations et sur les
distorsions montre les autorisations et
des usages mais il n'est pas le seul à
nous mentir
donc si on fait des procédures en par
jour on doit aller jusqu'où parce que
manifestement le secrétaire général de
la présidence de la république le
directeur de cabinet le chef de cabinet
du président de la république nous ont
tous menti ils ont commencé par nous
expliquer qu'à l'action de benalla ne
s'occuper que de l'organisation des
déplacements et éventuellement d'un peu
de protocoles de tout sauf de sécurité
et puis après on les a pris en
contradiction avec les faits alors il ya
pas seulement les déclarations des
syndicats qui sont peut-être un peu
exagéré mais qu'ils exactement le
contraire puisqu'il parlait même de
barbouzes ou de milices privées à la
présidence de la république
mais il ya aussi cet arrêté du préfet de
police qui octroie qui autorise ses
bananes à porter une arme pour ses
missions de protection de sécurité à
l'elysée donc on en totale contradiction
avec lui sont des puits après des lignes
de défense
et si elle était unique pour tous ont
tout de même bouger nous a dit après
mais vous comprenez pour organiser les
voyages tout allait bien coordonnée
compris la sécurité qui a prôné jeudi à
manon la coordination c'était la
coordination des forces de sécurité
néanmoins réentend de certaines
personnes mais est-ce utile de
réentendre des gens qui nous mentent bon
on peut toujours mais je crois pas que
ça fera beaucoup avancé je crois
qu'aujourd'hui nationale alain giblet un
directeur de lanton publiques à la
préfecture de police de paris avait
demandé aux députés d'être réentendu
puisqu'il s'était lui-même suivi du mi7
s'était trompé alors est-ce que si on
réentend aujourd'hui le directeur de
cabinet du présent à bully coule sur les
terrains après dix ans ils nous diront
autre chose que ce qu'ils nous ont dit
qu'ils aient depuis complètement
démentie par les faits je crois que on
n'a peut-être pas plus de moyens c'est à
dire d'investigation matériel mais quand
on nous explique que cet arrêté
maintenant à monsieur benalla qui nous
explique s'occuper tout sauf de sécurité
pourquoi
l'arrêté du préfet de police fait
mention de sa mission de sécurité nous
expliqua bah je sais pas il faut
demander à l'un services de la
préfecture de police et la préfecture de
police en sait plus trop qui l'a fait
non nous expliquons qu'on a fait à la
demande de 2,2 en fait à la demande de
l'elysée la demande de l'elysée qui
aurait dû être écrite aurait parait-il
et et verbale c'est un coup de fil
voyez rien qui tient